The year was 1997.
Bill Clinton was sworn in for the second
time as US president,
the United Kingdom transferred the
sovereignty of Hong Kong to China,
effectively ending the British empire.
Scientists cloned a sheep at the Roslyn
institute in Scotland,
and Catherine Hettinger,
an inventor from Tulsa,
Oklahoma,
filed a patent in Washington dc for what
was then called the spinning toy,
what the world knows now as the fidget
spinner was an invention born out of
paint in the early nineties,
living in Florida,
passenger was suffering from my
Asthenia,
gravis and neuromuscular disease that
causes weakness in the skeletal muscles.
I couldn't pick up her toys or play with
them at all.
Hettinger says of her then young
daughter,
so I started throwing things together
with newspaper and tape than other
stuff.
It wasn't really even prototyping.
It was some semblance of something.
It wasn't long until that semblance
began to take shape.
Pittenger flew with her daughter to our
nation's capital to patent her new
invention with the anticipation perhaps
of a gold rush
shopping for the next furby.
That was the goal at the sixth annual
toy and decoration affair.
At the Metro Toronto Convention Center,
our own young at heart reporter Brian
Hatchell stuff by
say hello to crazy bones.
These small plastic figurines come and
dozens of shapes and sizes and cost
about a buck each.
The 19 nineties were of course no
stranger to toy crisis,
whether it was crazy bones or pugs,
furbies or Tamagotchi.
Every year the world was once again
possessed with a new favorite toy.
No one could guess what was going to be
next.
Toy makers would have paid handsomely to
anybody who could,
but each time the new craze seemed to
sink pointedly with the national
character.
What is Jack?
I think there's anything tremendously
philosophic about it.
I don't think it's any metaphysical.
I just think it's
which one to watch.
Suck it up and scrub it up with a guy
back.
Pop it up and pull it up later.
If Catherine hettinger returned from
Washington DC with magnificent images of
GAC swirling around in her head,
who could blame her and for awhile it
looked,
those gaps soak dreams would become a
reality.
The mammoth toy company,
Hasbro agreed to test headend jurors
finger spinners.
Unfortunately,
in the end they decided not to move
forward with the production and some
things that should not have been
forgotten or lost.
History became legend.
Legend became myth,
and for two decades the spinning toy
passed out of all knowledge until when
chance came,
it ensnared a new generation.
They are popping up more and more in
schools and stores are really having a
hard time keeping them on the shelves.
I'm talking about fidget spinners or
fidget spinners.
We'll call them fidget spinners,
fidget widgets or whatever you'd like.
Fidget,
spinner,
fidget spinners is caught a fidget
spinner.
My daughter has one.
You just kind of put on your finger and
spin it around like this though.
No one can say when exactly the fidget
spinner came to America.
In late 2016 reality TV star,
Donald trump had been elected.
The 45th president of the United States.
All cell phones had lost physical
buttons in favor of touchscreens and two
brothers,
mark and Matthew Mclaughlin had just
unexpectedly raised $6,000,000
for a trinket called the fidget cube,
which a great story.
It's a human story.
It's a story of those who went first.
They were first.
They led the way they opened the trail.
It's obvious to everyone that the fidget
cube is fun.
I mean just look at it,
but it was much more than that.
Citing a study from the Australian
Journal of learning difficulties.
A claim was made that these game
changing toys could actually help those
afflicted with Adhd to focus better,
engaging in fine motor activity.
The study said may assist students with
Adhd in resisting the pool of
distraction and then two days before
Christmas fidget spinners dormant for
almost two decades,
except in certain underground fidget
circles exploded like lightening onto
the scene.
It's more exciting than than this makes
it seem these days
fidget spinners are everywhere.
They're in office cubicles and
playgrounds in hospitals and locker
rooms.
Even in the White House,
everything must be perfectly done and
they weren't working in a production
line and you have to get so many pieces
done per hour,
but it all had to be perfectly done and
it does extend to you as you look at it,
the sense of serenity
for months.
The spinner is medical benefits were
hotly contested by news websites with
nothing better to do.
Apparently they were banned from
classrooms across the globe.
You could find them everywhere and
nowhere.
And what about Catherine Hettinger?
That of course is the great tragedy of
this story in 2005 and the long dark
calm before the fidget store,
Hettinger was forced to let her patent
expire because she couldn't afford $400
renewal fee.
Since then,
the inventor of the fidget spinner
hasn't seen a dime of the prophets of
the most successful product of all time.
Anything really new in thought and
material life has to have its source in
something you have to go spiritual.
Nobody can be really creative and unless
there's something spiritual behind it,
whether you,
whether it's goes by that name or not,
I mean who invented the house,
who invented any of the things?
We have probably someone engaged in some
kind of search.
This episode was brought to you by
squarespace.
If you want to make a website and you
want it to be a really easy process,
squarespace has some beautiful award
winning designer templates to choose
from.
That makes the process really simple.
It's got 24 hour customer service,
no upgrades,
nothing to install,
no patches ever,
and picking your domain name is really
easy.
You can start your free
trial@squarespace.com,
and if you use the offer code
nerdwriter,
you can get 10 percent off your first
purchase.
Thanks guys.
I'll see you next time.